[Música]
shanghai una ciudad con más de 25
millones de habitantes y uno de los
motores económicos de china es el centro
un nuevo brote de cubit 19 que desafía
la estricta política cero cobit de las
autoridades chinas los habitantes de la
urbe se encuentran confinados desde el
pasado 28 de marzo y ahora sufren de
ansiedad desesperación y enfrentan
además la escasez de alimentos y
productos de primera necesidad las
situaciones realmente tensas que las
autoridades aíslan a las personas que
dan positivo incluso si son
asintomáticas ubicándolas en centros de
cuarentena pero con más de 28 mil nuevos
casos diarios en los últimos días el
aislamiento sistemático pues por
supuesto se va a ir complicando hoy se
conoció la muerte de tres adultos
mayores consecuencia del cob y 19 para
ello entonces quiero saludar a nuestro
segundo invitado del día ls daniela
lópez acuña epidemiólogo daniel lópez
acuña perdón epidemiólogo y ex director
de acción sanitaria la organización
mundial de la salud gracias doctor
daniel por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 que está ocurriendo
realmente en
bueno yo creo que lo que tenemos es que
contextualizar lo que ocurre en shanghai
y entender por qué se responde de la
manera que se responde en china- en
estos momentos shanghai en particular
está experimentando un incremento
notable de incidencias como no lo había
visto a lo largo de dos años
la incidencia en shanghai como ha
ocurrido en en vietnam como ha ocurrido
en corea del sur ha ocurrido en hong
kong se ha disparado a los niveles de
altos de incidencia como los observados
en europa en la temporada otoño invernal
ante eso y pues después de haber seguido
una política de la llamada kobe 0 que
también es una una estrategia que no no
estaba rindiendo los resultados que se
piense que puede rendir
lo que le lo que tiene que enfrentar el
gobierno de china y la ciudad de
shanghai es contener la transmisión y
para contener la transmisión pues no
tiene más remedio que hacer el
confinamiento como lo ha hecho que es
como se tuvo que proceder con
confinamientos drásticos draconianos al
inicio de la pandemia en escenarios como
es el caso de euro y hay que entender
que la vacunación
basta para evitar la transmisión la
vacunación reduce la proporción de
personas que tienen casos severos que
tienen muerte pero no elimina los
contagios y entonces lo que china tiene
que hacer en estos momentos es hacer
todo lo posible para no sobresaturar su
estructura asistencial para poder
contener la transmisión y para poder
frenar la expansión del virus y el
incremento de incidencia claro doctor
por esta política tan estricta si
realmente ha tenido los resultados que
quiere el gobierno porque sabe estamos
viendo igual 28 mil hasta 30 mil casos
diarios de kobe 19 ya la gente
obviamente desesperada en sus casas o
está estamos viendo incluso a algunos lo
comparan con un confinamiento más
estricto que a la casi que al principio
de la pandemia o igual entonces que
realmente tienen que hacer las
autoridades sigamos si lo comparamos con
países occidentales cuando ya levantaba
la mayoría de las restricciones de
tapabocas pues la diferencia y por qué
china está apelando a esta política
bueno primero no se puede comparar con
la situación de países occidentales y no
se puede sobre simplificar pensando que
allá se está llevando a cabo una acción
extrema y en los países occidentales
estamos declarando la independencia del
hobbit el hobbit sigue la pandemia
persiste en los países occidentales que
están quitando las restricciones por la
mascarilla en interiores se están
equivocando al por qué lo están haciendo
cuando todavía hay transmisión
comunitaria y puede haber un riesgo
importante de rebrotes china ha
enfrentado la presencia de una nueva
variante un número elevado de casos los
confinamientos darán resultados no en el
sentido de que se acabe el número de
casos de la noche a la mañana sino que
se reduzca el ritmo de transmisión yo
creo que el peor error que podemos
cometer es pensar es que ahí se actúa
excesivamente no ahí se está actuando de
acuerdo a la situación epidemiológica
existiendo entonces por supuesto que
habrá que intensificar las medidas de
protección las restricciones hacen bien
en hacerla el aislamiento de personas
positivas a síntomas y los países
occidentales que han eliminado esa
medida se han equivocado también el
hecho de que una persona no tenga
síntomas no quiere decir que no
transmita la enfermedad yo creo que nos
está faltando a entender que esta no es
una carrera hacia una falsa libertad de
no usar mascarilla o de pensar que el
virus ya no existe queremos todos que se
termine la dinámica pandémica que hemos
vivido a lo largo de estos dos años pero
para ello tenemos que poner a raya al
virus a través de las medidas que sean
pertinentes según la situación en
tecnología porque los países
occidentales entonces doctores están
tomando estas medidas de esa libertad
que usted dijo obviar entre comillas en
la pandemia del cob y 19 están apelando
entonces al contagio de rebaño para la
inmunización
bueno primero científicamente sabemos
que la inmunidad de rebaño no se produce
en el caso de espolí 10 en algunos
países desde el inicio de la pandemia
fue el caso del reino unido por ejemplo
en américa latina lo hizo brasil
pensaron que lo que había que hacer era
dejar que la gente se contagiase para
tener una mayor inmunidad pensando que
se podía ver lograr una inmunidad
hay un planteamiento desde el inicio de
la pandemia
que se denomina el gran barrington de
tradición de un grupo de científicos que
estuvieron a favor de dejar correr la
infección bueno esto lo que ha mostrado
es en muchos países lo que generó esta
situación fue un número elevadísimo de
casos y un altísimo número de muertes en
personas mayores y en personas
vulnerables nuestro objetivo tiene que
ser siempre el interrumpir la
transmisión es minimizar los contagios
para que no tengamos hobbits
persistentes para que no tengamos
presión asistencial para que no
enfrentemos una situación de alta
mortalidad aún con altas tasas de
vacunación por la presencia de variantes
que son todavía altamente contagiosas y
porque todavía tenemos grupos de
población que no están plenamente
vacunados cuando los países occidentales
han dado estos pasos son muchas veces de
cara a la galería' por una razón o una
lógica más política pero hay países que
han tenido que volver a instalar las
mascarillas de acción es el caso de
austria y mi recomendación sería
cautela precaución con levantar medidas
que nos protegen cuando todavía tenemos
una incidencia elevada y cuando el virus
todavía circula de manera comunitaria y
se transmite de manera única claro